if you think so Mars is a harsh place
you are Musk SpaceX and other folks NASA
are really pushing to put a human being
on Mars do you think again let's forgive
me for lingering in science fiction land
for a little bit do you think one day we
may be able to colonize Mars first do
you think we'll put a human on Mars and
then do you think we'll put many humans
on Mars so first of all we're not I I am
extraordinarily convinced we will not
put a human on Mars by 2030 which is a
date that you often hear in the public
debate what's the challenge there well
you think so there are a couple of ways
that I could slice this but the one that
I think is simplest for people and
understand involves money so you look at
how we got to the moon in the 1960s
there's about ten year duration between
the challenge that President Kennedy
laid out and our successfully landing a
moon I was actually here at MIT when
that first moon landing occurred so I
remember watching it on TV but how do we
get there well we had this extraordinary
technical agency of the United States
government NASA it consumed about 5% of
the country's economic output and so you
say 5% of the economic output over about
a 10-year period gets us 250,000 miles
in space Mars is about a hundred times
farther so you have at least a hundred
times a challenge and we're spending
about one tenth of the funds that we
spent then as a government so my claim
is is that it's at least a thousand
times harder for me to imagine that's
getting to Mars by 2030 and yet that
part they mentioned in the speech that I
just have to throw in there of JFK of we
do these things not because they're easy
but because they're hard it's such a
beautiful line that I would love to hear
a modern president say about a
scientific endeavor well one day we live
in hope that such a president will arise
for our nation but even if like I said
even if you you fix the proper technical
problems the biological engineering that
I worry most about
however I'm gonna go out on a limb here
I think that by two thousand ninety or
so or two thousand one hundred and so
let's say one hundred twenty I suspect
we're gonna have a human on Mars
Wow so you think that many years out
first a few tangents he said
bioengineering is the chair as a
challenge of whoa what's what's the
challenge there so as I said the the
real problem with interstellar travel
aside from the technology challenges
the real problem is radiation and how do
you engineer either an environment or a
body because we see rapid advances going
on in bioengineering how do you engineer
either a ship or body so that something
is some person that's recognizably Union
human will survive the rigors of
interplanetary space travel it's much
more difficult than most people seem to
take into account so if we could linger
on the 2090 2121 twenty sort of thinking
of that kind of you know and we let's
linger on money
okay so Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos are
pushing the cost trying to click push
the cost down I mean this is so do you
have hope as this actually a sort of a
brilliant big-picture scientist do you
think a business entrepreneur can take
science and make it cheaper and get it
out there faster so bending the cost
curve is you'll notice that has been an
anchor this is a simplest way for me to
discuss this with people about what the
challenge is so yes bending the cost
curve is certainly critical if we're
going to be successful now you asked
about the endeavors that are out there
now sponsored by two very prominent
American citizens Jeff Bezos and Elon
Musk
I'm disappointed actually in what I see
in terms of the routes that are being
pursued so let me give you one example
there and this one is going to be a
little bit more technical
so if you look at the kinds of rockets
that both these organizations are
creating yes it's wonderful reusable
technology to see a rocket go up and
land on its fins just like it did in
science fiction movies when I was a kid
that's astounding
but the real problem is those Rockets
the technology that we're doing now is
not really that different than what was
used to go to the moon and there are
alternatives it turns out there's an
engine called a flare engine which so a
traditional rocket if you look at the
engine looks like a bell right and then
the flame comes out the bottom
but there is a kind of engine called a
flare engine which is essentially when
you look at it it looks like an exhaust
pipe on like a fancy car that's you know
long and it elongate it and it's a type
of rocket engine that we know we know
it's there been preliminary testing we
know it works and it also is actually
much more economical because what it
does is allow you to vary the amount of
thrust as you go up in a way that you
cannot do with one of these bell shaped
engines so you would think that an
entrepreneur might try to have to break
through to use flared nozzles as they're
called as a way to bend the cost curve
because we keep coming back that's going
to be a big factor but that's not
happening in fact what we see is what I
think of as incremental change in terms
of our technology so I'm not really very
encouraged by what I personally see
telling commands I'll change won't Bend
cost curve and I don't see it
you